the trial of kyle rittenhouse had been
going extremely poorly for the
prosecution it had been going extremely
well for the defense all that was left
to do for the jury was to acquit
and yet
before they could do that the defense
made a dramatic potentially catastrophic
decision they called kyle rittenhouse
himself to the stand
one wrong word could have upended the
whole thing could have sent this kid to
jail for life and yet
he knocked it out of the park and he
exposed the entire media narrative
around him as a sham and i hope he
becomes a trillionaire suing every
single dirt bag journalist and
politician who slandered and libeled him
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from travis landers
who says twilight zone theme
imagine if you will a drug so safe
you are bribed with fornication to take
it
fornication and cheeseburgers and french
fries all to take the fauciachi because
of how safe and effective and desirable
it is that makes sense doesn't it i'm
not so sure things are getting a little
wonky in this country politically
economically just look at gas prices if
you want to save money at the pump
you got to check out get upside i am so
happy to bring you an incredible app
right now i don't think we've ever had a
more timely advertiser get upside
our listeners are making up to 25 cents
for every gallon of gas every time they
fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code knowles k
wles get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on
your first fill up that's 50 cents cash
back don't pay full price at the pump
anymore get cash back using get upside
down the app for free
use promo code knowles kwles to get up
to 50 cents per gallon cash back on your
first tank
some people who drive a lot are making
as much as two to three hundred dollars
a month in cash back and there's no
catch guess we're added right to your
bank account you can cash out through
your bank account paypal
even an e-gift card to amazon and other
brands download the free get upside app
right now use promo code nulls to get up
to 50 cents per gallon cashback on your
first tank that is code knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s you can thank me later i
want to correct the record on something
here because i'm seeing
a line go around the internet and all
the commentary around the kyle ritton
house case and the line is true enough
but it
i think it implies something that's not
true everyone's pointing out that the
prosecution is incompetent
the the prosecuting attorney and the
whole case that the state is making is
just really weak and the lawyer who's
giving it is really weak and that's true
he's not a very good prosecutor but
that's if kyle rittenhouse gets off
that's not why he will get off he will
get off because all of the evidence in
the case is on his side and none of the
evidence is on the side of the state you
could have the dream team you could have
johnny cochran and alan dershowitz and i
don't know ken starr and all the all the
great top lawyers in the country working
for the prosecution working for the
state here they still would not be able
to make a convincing case that kyle
rittenhouse is guilty of what they're
accusing him of so
at issue here is
the fact that kyle rittenhouse shot
three people
killed two of them one of them he didn't
kill
was he the aggressor here was this
reckless was he trying to commit murder
or was he acting in self-defense
so the prosecutor
just tries to nail him and it says are
you did you intend to kill these people
everybody that you shot at that night
you intended to kill
correct
i didn't intend to kill them i intended
to i intended to stop the people who
were attacking me
by killing them
i did what i had to do to stop the
person who was attacking me
by killing them
two of them passed away but i stopped
the threat from attacking me
by using deadly force i used deadly
force
that you knew was going to kill
i didn't know if it was going to kill
them but i i used the i used deadly
force to stop the threat that was
attacking me
you intentionally used deadly force
against joseph rosenbaum correct yes you
intentionally use deadly force against
the man who came and tried to kick you
in the face correct
you intentionally use deadly force
against anthony huber correct
you intentionally use deadly force
against gage gross courts correct yes
with regard to joseph rosenbaum you
fired four shots at him correct yes you
intended to kill him correct i didn't
intend to kill him i intended to stop
the person who was attacking me and
trying to steal my gun
this answer is so sophisticated and i
can't tell if the prosecutor is just
stupid or if he's playing dumb but this
is an actual important distinction it's
it's the law of double effect
okay the kid kyle rittenhouse did not
set out
to kill these people
if he had set out to kill these people
he would have been the aggressor right
he would have just gone out with his gun
and just found a bunch of people to kill
in every case he only shot at people who
were attacking him and he didn't even
kill everyone that he
fired at who was attacking him
so
you heard the prosecutor say you you
were stopping the four stopping the
threat
by killing them but he actually didn't
kill everyone one of the people that he
shot at
testified during this trial and actually
testified that kyle rittenhouse was
acting in self-defense
so then the prosecution focuses on this
guy joseph rosenbaum who's a kid diddler
he was a child rapist who kyle
rittenhouse put out of his misery as
this guy was attacking him
and
they say you intended to kill this man
and kyle rittenheim says no i intended
to stop the threat that was coming at me
if as a consequence of stopping the
threat
the person died well that's a second
effect that's a secondary effect of my
stopping the threat but but let's be
very clear here i wasn't here out for
blood just trying to kill everybody i
i waited until the last moment until it
was absolutely the threat was coming at
me and in every single case video
evidence testimony has proven that to be
the case
so the prosecutor because he's maybe a
little thick in the head or maybe he's
just desperate and he's out of options
here he says well hold on why do you
think that the people who were coming at
you and attacking you were the threat
you had a gun weren't you the threat to
them
can you help me understand mr
rittenhouse why
gage gross courts
with a pistol in his hand
is a threat to kill you
but you with an ar-15 pointed at him is
not a threat to kill him at this moment
can you understand that
i've been attacked by several people and
he decided to come and
point a gun at my head well first he
hasn't done that yet has he no
so again i ask you in this moment
you told us gage gross quotes is a
threat to you right now yes
he's got a pistol not aimed at you
you've got an ar-15 aimed at him
why is he more of a threat to you
than you are to him
because he was he was moving at me with
a gun in his hand
it's a very simple answer so the
prosecution thinks he's got him on this
image right the the other guy at at
least at one moment doesn't have the gun
aimed at written house but rittenhouse
has his gun aimed at the other guy
why isn't rittenhouse the threat here
why is this
because the other guy is advancing on
him
rittenhouse is in the defensive position
the other guy is in the aggressing
position with a gun in his hand
obviously justifies lethal force for
self defense
this the prosecution not impressive
at all he
he he apparently doesn't even know
anything about the guns and keeps asking
rittenhouse where where did you get this
fascination with ar-15s from
you picked it out because it looked
cool i thought it looked cool
that's the reason yes it resembled the
types of weapons that are used in first
person shooter video games correct
i don't really play first person shooter
video games i have but i believe there's
a variety of guns including
shotguns pistols
there's guns and video games that
resemble all guns isn't it true when you
would hang out with dominic black you'd
play call of duty and other first-person
shooter video games
sometimes
and those are games in which you use
weapons like ar-15s to pretty much shoot
anybody who comes at you correct
it's a video game where two players are
playing together
i don't really understand the meaning of
your question to be honest isn't one of
the things people do in these video
games try and kill everyone else with
your guns
yeah the video game it's just a video
game it's not real life
isn't it true mr rittenhouse that you
and your friends
used to play cowboys and indians
yeah didn't you mr rittenhouse
i would like to introduce exhibit a a
cap gun
that mr rittenhouse was given for his
10th birthday and when you played
cowboys and indians mr rittenhouse
didn't you point the guns at each other
and go bang bang bang
the prosecution rests its case your
honor this boy played games as a child
russ mike and
uh isn't it true mr rittenhouse that a
cap gun
like an ar-15 is a
is a type of gun it looks like a gun
yeah that's it that's and that's the by
the way that's the best they had
that's the best case the prosecution
made
as far as i'm concerned all trial
is that kyle rittenhouse
played video games
sometimes
this is why it was so impressive that
they brought written house to the stand
they didn't they didn't need to
it was a big gamble
and
i'm i'm beginning to think the reason
they did that is not to gain any
advantage legally i think legally
speaking they had
everything to lose and nothing to gain
but i think this went further than that
i think this was about a kid who was
trying to clear his name who is trying
to focus not just on the court of law
here but the court of public opinion
where the media had just been absolutely
slandering him libeling him smearing him
for months and months and months
and this kid was confident enough and
had the evidence and the truth on his
side that he went up there when you want
to protect yourself
i would recommend you check out lifelock
these days some surveillance apps known
as stalkerware can collect information
from you while avoiding detection by
pretending to be something else
stalkerware silently sits in the
background collecting data doing things
like recording calls and keystrokes and
stealing your photos and sending the
info it gathers to whomever is spying on
you it's important to understand how
cyber crime and identity theft are
affecting our lives every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could steal
what's yours sometimes even harm your
finances your credit your reputation
good thing there's lifelock lifelock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
for sale on the dark web if they detect
your information has potentially been
compromised they will send you an alert
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions to all
businesses but you can help protect
what's yours with lifelock by norton
join now save up to 25 percent off your
first year by going to lifelock.com
knowles canadawles lifelock.com knowles
kowles for 25
off
the judge in the the written house trial
at a certain point had just had it with
the prosecution and reamed the
prosecution on multiple occasions you
are already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that and it
gives
well i'll leave it at that
so i don't know what you're up to the
problem is this is a grave
constitutional violation for you to talk
about the defendants silence
and that is and and in your right
you're right on the you're right on the
border line
and you may
you may be over but uh it better stop so
the prosecution because he had nothing
else said hey how come
kyle
how come he um
exercised his right to remain silent you
know his constitutional right you know
the miranda rights that you are read
when you're arrested
the fact that he exercised those huh
probably probably means he's guilty
right this is a as the judge says a
grave constitutional violation
you would learn this forget about
law school you would learn this in
undergraduate pre-law classes
and yet this prosecutor seems to have
forgotten it the
the most dramatic moment of of the whole
testimony which is which is really
getting the most play right now is where
kyle rittenhouse is recalling the events
and he breaks down and he starts crying
once i take that step back i look over
my shoulder and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
um
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
people right there
okay so this this is really hard to
watch because he's still just 18 right
and that this happened when when the kid
was 17 here was the only time you really
remember this is a pretty young guy
i guess now you would you'd say he was a
kid
eight months ago now you now you'd say i
guess he's technically an adult but just
just barely
the left is accusing him of crocodile
tears of faking it of going up there to
fake it to try to gin up uh
sympathy and they're saying that
actually if you look he's not even
really crying there aren't any tears
coming down so you know it's all he's
just he's just a big faker
i think they're missing the point here
i don't think that kyle rittenhouse is
crying because he did something wrong
that's that's the whole point of the
defense is he didn't do anything wrong
every single shot that kyle rittenhouse
took
was a good shot
was a justified shot
they didn't even really go astray they
weren't excessive
right he was waiting until the threat
was there so it i don't think he's
crying because he regrets anything he
did he didn't do anything wrong
according to all the evidence we've seen
he's crying because of the trauma of
this
what he's crying because he's got
post-traumatic stress
wouldn't you
wouldn't you
as an adult
let's say you were an adult with much
more life experience perhaps with much
more firearms training if you had to
live through this if you were being
chased down by pedophile rapists and
criminals and thug
antifa rioters
and you in this moment where your life
is being threatened and you take these
shots and you end up killing
a couple of people
and injuring another person you're on
trial and you're smeared as a terrorist
and whites don't you think reliving that
moment you might have a little bit of a
reaction
he didn't have a an emotional
um you know regretful lamentation type
of outburst
he had a panic attack up there
to me the the readout first of all i
think his his testimony was so
articulate it was so
tight and the prosecution had nothing on
him that i think he did an incredible
job
but
also the fact that he had a panic attack
reliving this moment to me
makes the testimony even more
credible
i think i think he did great it was a
crazy move to call him to the stand and
he knocked it out of the park so there's
a chance he might be vindicated in court
despite already being convicted in the
court of public opinion just a little
trip down memory lane
ridden house is basically what you would
have had in a school shooter he's a 17
year old kid he shouldn't have had a gun
he crossed state lines to supposedly
protect property no he was going out to
shoot people kyle rittenhouse the 17
year old vigilante kyle rittenhouse the
vigilante kyle rittenhouse the armed
teenage vigilante a 17 year old
vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people kyle rittenhouse
a guy who's deeply racist went with
weapons to a black lives matter protest
looking to get in trouble he did he
murdered a couple of people rittenhouse
uh the 17 year old kid
just running around shooting and killing
protesters you see the 17 year old who
was radicalized by trumpism took his
ar-15 to kenosha and became a killer a
white trump-supporting
maga-loving uh blue lives matter social
media
partisan 17 years old picks up a gun
drives from one state to another with
the intent to shoot people
complete lies
completely the only thing they said
there that's true is he drove from one
state to another but there was they were
right over the border it's not be like
me driving
to franklin i'm in nashville it'd be
like me driving to franklin it's like
it's not
it's not like driving hours and hours
out of state he's driving to the place
where he worked place where his father
lives
and he didn't go there to go kill people
he only shot in self-defense
why did he go armed i don't because he
was going into a riot zone where his dad
lived and where he worked
i'm glad he went armed
i'm glad he went armed otherwise these
guys very likely would have killed him
i hope rittenhouse sues every one of
these dirt bags the the lincoln project
guy i forget his name the bald lincoln
project guy
i don't know why pedophiles keep keep
playing into this narrative so much both
the
assailant in kenosha and now we're
talking about the lincoln project i hope
he sues him into the dirt i hope he sues
joe scarborough i hope he sues
all of these people
all of those msnbc people
hope he sues them into the ground i hope
he becomes a gazillionaire
i hope he pulls a nick sandman you
remember the kid the smiling kid
who was being accosted by that lunatic
indian man at the lincoln memorial and
by the black supremacists who were
screaming all sorts and he just stood
there smiling in a maga hat and and the
media smeared him too and then he got
settlements from cnn and i hope
i hope i hope this kid gets the exact
same thing in other narrative news
george floyd is getting a geography
there's a new book coming out it's a
biography of george floyd talk about
people who don't need biographies uh
he's getting a biography published may
17 2022
this is going to be coming out from one
of the imprints of penguin random house
a very prestigious publishing house
here's the press release quote
the biography of george floyd shows the
athletic young boy raised in the
projects of houston's third ward who
would become a father a partner a friend
and a man constantly in search of a
better life
oh yeah is that is that so in
retracing floyd's story samuels and olo
renipa these are two washington post
reporters
bring to light the determination floyd
carried as he faced the relentless
struggle to survive as a black man in
america
now i'm going to translate that from the
delusional fantasy of penguin random
house into reality
george floyd was a career criminal who
robbed a pregnant woman at gunpoint and
never turned his life around ever and in
his final moments was only killed
because he was resisting arrest and
committing a crime at his very last
moments and was super duper high on
drugs had taken a lethal dose of drugs
never ever once improved his life
and was
for his entire career a menace to
society
and
did not have a constant struggle
to survive as a black man in america
made very very bad choices
i think that book
i think that book would be a lot more
honest if you wrote that about but i i
don't think that one would get published
i think instead
you have this fantasy this new what this
is about obviously this has nothing to
do with george floyd the book that
they're publishing
it has to do with the narrative
white people bad black people good
really easy for white people to live
very hard for black people to live
george floyd saint martyr
a hero a demigod
even if that story is false it gets to a
greater truth here's the narrative kyle
kyle rittenhouse evil white supremacist
terrorist
all the
pedophile rapist career criminal rioters
who were chasing him are good wonderful
saintly anti-racist protesters and even
if the reality isn't isn't that
even if that narrative is a lie
it gets to
a greater truth what it gets to is a
fantasy but it's a fantasy with a lot of
institutional backing
you gotta take
you gotta you gotta fight really hard to
get those wins you gotta take the wins
where you can get them one win you can
get is refinancing your home i recommend
you check out american financing there
is still time to make a positive impact
on your budget before a year-end as
mortgage rates remain near money-saving
lows now you might be thinking
why
my mortgage it's fine as it is
well what you should be asking is how
can my mortgage work for me and that
answer can be found at american
financing america's home for home loans
they don't pressure you instead their
salary based mortgage consultants get to
know you so they can lead you to greater
overall savings it could be a shorter
loan term or consolidating debt because
there is more to a refinance than just a
lower rate and it's the reason why they
save customers up to a thousand dollars
per month so why not see what they can
do for you
right now call 800 685
that is 8685-5696
or visit americanfinancing.net
nmls
182-334-nmls consumer access
as i think we've mentioned on this show
before
we got a fight
for our basic rights here the biden
administration is pushing a vaccine
mandate the daily wire is not backing
down we filed a lawsuit against this
unconstitutional mandate a week ago
today we're already seeing results the
fifth circuit court of appeals has
issued a temporary stay
preventing the biden mandate from going
into effect citing quote grave statutory
and constitutional issues this does not
mean the battle is over rather it means
that the battle has just begun this is
urgent this is a very very time
sensitive matter your medical freedom
depends on it if you want to support the
fight to make your personal medical
decisions without
interference from your government or
from your employers for that matter sign
our petition against biden's mandate
hundreds of thousands of americans have
already signed the petition in just a
few days but we need many more people to
stand with us to reach our goal head on
over to dailywire.com do not comply to
sign the petition today we'll be right
back with a lot more
rioters good people who defend
themselves bad criminals such as george
floyd good
cops
bad that's the new national narrative
that's the new national myth so how does
this play out in real life
about a week ago
less than a week ago
the 50th person
this year
was arrested in chicago
for
murder while out on felony bond
the 50th person this year in chicago
was arrested for murder while he should
have been in jail
okay
the cwb chicago reported that uh this
new fellow edmund harris was arrested on
february 12th so quite a while ago
uh though that the report has just come
out quote after he allegedly crashed a
hijacked suv in lawndale harris was not
charged for any crime related to
carjacking or crash and was instead
charged quote with failure to register
as a sex offender in an unrelated manner
okay so that was back in february
now
failing to register as a sex offender
a lot of sex offenders in the news these
days
is a felony but didn't matter harris was
released a few days after his arrest
because he posted a thousand buck
deposit for felony bond
five weeks after he posted that thousand
dollar bail bond he killed a 31 year old
uber driver in another carjacking this
according to
federal prosecutors
there's the compassion for you
there's the mercy
we're told
that when we arrest people when we
arrest criminals especially when we
arrest black criminals that's the worst
you're not allowed to do that
that is terrible and it's white
supremacist and
it's cruel and unusual and we need we
shouldn't do that we need to abolish
prisons we need to get rid of the police
we need to stop arresting criminals that
will be really compassionate was it
compassionate to the 31 year old uber
driver 31 that's how old i am
life is over
did that uber driver have a wife
or a husband i guess
did that did that uber driver have kids
i don't know maybe
i do i have a wife and kids
well
what would the compassion be there if uh
for my wife and my son
if some thug criminal who should be
behind bars paying his debt to society
had just been released because you know
hey
that's it's because of what the color of
his skin because we want to go easy on
criminals for whatever reason and then
he goes out
and killed me or killed you or killed
someone 31 years old
there's the compassion
the libs want to do this they want they
want they want to set up specifically a
racial caste system here where
black people people of color is the
broad term get preferential treatment
and they're trying to conflate issues of
race and the criminal justice system
because there are a lot of people of
color in prison because people of color
are overrepresented to use the popular
term in crime statistics and so they say
that's why as a racial matter we've got
to
abolish prisons or whatever
they want to do this and the republicans
are buying into it this is what's so
upsetting to me i mean it's really awful
news in chicago they got it they got to
turn this around i think that the more
just compassionate thing to do would be
to lock up the criminals and keep them
from harming other people
but
you notice that republicans have adopted
this thing too
donald trump did it it was one of his
signature achievements the first step
act
also known as the jailbreak bill i love
trump i voted for him the first time
he did some stuff that i didn't like i
still voted for him the second time
because he did a lot of things that i
think were really good and really
courageous and took a lot of guts
but this is something republicans just
have lost their minds over
republicans should not be running on
letting more criminals out of prison
they should not be running on the lie
that we have an over-incarceration
problem in the united states
looking around at our city's burning and
murder rates skyrocketing and carjacking
i think we have an under incarceration
problem in the united states
and my evidence for that is crime is
going through the roof so lock them up
good grief these republicans are a
little too clever by half
they think oh you know look if i push
for criminal criminal justice reform
meaning let the letting the criminals
out of jail
then that will i'll seem i won't seem
racist the left won't call me a racist
anymore i hint they will and we're going
to win over all sorts of new voters uh
hint you won't and that'll be really
good for everybody it won't be good it
won't it actually won't be good for
anybody including the criminals who who
should be getting rehabilitated in the
can
speaking of misplaced compassion
steve ducey or rather peter ducey steve
ducey's on the morning show peter ducey
the white house reporter is
uh presently just
destroying the white house deputy press
secretary corrine jean-pierre
ducey asked karine jean-pierre
about this biden administration policy
to give massive six-figure
mid-six-figure payments
to illegal aliens
is there any kind of discussion about
giving people who are coming here the
right way money
why would i why would we be giving
people who are coming here the white ray
money why are you giving people who came
here
i mean but i i don't understand
the question what is uh you're saying
that we should give we should we should
give people just money who are coming
through i don't understand the question
giving people who immigrated here
illegally
like i said like i said that's the
department of justice that's you're
going to have to ask them that question
oh he got her
he so got her and he did it in a really
clever way the white house has been
stonewalling on this issue of them
giving six-figure payments you know 450
000 payments to illegal aliens
right and this is for the illegal aliens
who were separated whatever that means
uh during the trump administration even
though it's a policy that goes all the
way back to bill clinton
and they've been any time they get asked
about it they say no uh we refer you to
doj no we're not going to answer that no
comment moving on moving on and so what
peter peter ducey does here is he he
inverts the question he goes hey i just
wanted to know d um are you
is the white house planning on on giving
payments to illegal aliens or to to
immigrants who came to america the right
way through the legal channels
and the white house deputy secretary
looks like he goes what are you talking
about why would we do that that's insane
that's so crazy why would we just give
them money for coming here they're
immigrants they should be thanking us
they should be giving us money why would
we be giving them money
oh well because you're you are giving
money to people who are coming here
illegally so why
why aren't you giving money to people
who are coming here illegally and then
she realizes that she's not
she's not the best press secretary out
there okay jen saki is much better at
her job than this woman
and jin saki's not even that good at her
job
and she goes oh whoops oh never mind doj
doj well hold on you were answering the
question before before you realized that
it was a question
about a policy that you can't defend
ducey tries
again
now that the president is on the record
as of saturday supporting compensation
for illegal immigrants who are separated
from family at the border who
counts as separated if somebody was just
separated for a few hours or a few days
would they be eligible to settle a suit
and get this payment from doj so peter i
will direct you to the department of
justice for any specifics on that we
have we have you've asked us this
question we have answered it and i will
refer you to department of justice on
any specifics
if you've answered it then just answer
it again if it's such a simple answer
give us the answer again
oh you can because you haven't answered
it because there is no answer and ducey
brings up a good point here too what if
you were separated for an hour
you know you get you come into the
country illegally
you are being pro you're caught you're
being processed
and for an hour you're you're separated
from your kid and the kid is at hhs and
you're being processed by law
enforcement the kid's not going to be
processed by law enforcement
what about that and then you're back
together
are you entitled to almost half a
million dollars
just a question to my listeners out
there i'm sure some of you are pretty
well healed
but most i would say most people don't
have just half a million dollars lying
around
could you use that money do you think
do you think it would be nice if the
government gave you half a million
dollars
maybe maybe you need to go move down to
guatemala
and then
you know walk up hitch a ride and then
swim across the rio grande
so that's an easier way to make half a
million dollars than than most people
most people are not going to have half a
million bucks in their bank account
at any point in their lives
indefensible
and this this white house deputy press
secretary she didn't she didn't get any
better at it the more the questions
moved on
she was asked
a simple question what are what are you
guys doing about the rising gas prices
in california in some places gas is up
to around seven dollars a gallon in in
the united states that is insane i mean
that is some unprecedented
gas pricing
and they said what are you guys doing
about that
i think that's going to be the subject
of my next blank book
what options besides tapping the
strategic petroleum reserve does the
president have to counteract higher gas
prices so
um you know we've i've talked about this
a couple of times you know we we have we
don't have an announcement yet on
anything uh anything to share at this
time
uh you know but we're monitoring it
right we're monitoring the the prices
and we're making sure that we have tools
in our tool belt that we can uh we can
uh we can try and and use but at this
point at this time i don't have anything
new uh to share
are you reviewing because secretary
grant home has confirmed that is an
option that's on the table and the
president has said there are other tools
that he could potentially use so could
you just lay out what those other
options are that he's considering so i
don't again i don't i don't have
anything specific here the president
spoke to this recently but he's also
asked ftc to crack down on illegal
pricing right that is one thing that he
did on gouging in the market and the ftc
is responding but also we're going to
continue to monitor the situation and
have a number of tools in our arsenal as
i just mentioned i don't have anything
specific
how do you not have an answer to that
question i'm not saying how do you not
have an answer to the gas prices
obviously the biden administration is
not nearly competent enough to have that
answer but how do you as the press
secretary not show up prepared
for that
question
but the story here to me is not just
that this woman's bad at her job because
jinsaki is not that good at it either
remember she keeps circling back all the
time
it's not even about the gas prices or
the illegal alien payments
it's a story about the media as it very
often is
kaylee mcinanny our
wonderful former press secretary made
all of our hearts go pitter-patter she
was just she was so great at that job
she would show up with a binder that was
like six inches thick with all these
little annotations and any question any
question you had for her she'd open up
the binder and have an answer kaylee
what should i have for breakfast on
tuesday well thank you great question
you should have an egg
with some sausage and bacon and uh a
muffin and how what i don't know because
it's in my binders because she had such
details here this is a basic question
hey what are you guys doing about gas um
we don't
uh we don't um
so we have tool we totally have tools in
our arsenal we totally have an answer to
that but we're uh just not going to tell
you
but we have it you know i
i totally have a boyfriend but he lives
in canada um but it's he's totally real
but we i can't tell you anything about
him and there's no evidence that
that it's real
and the media don't care they think that
they're walking and gensake especially
in the early days of her tenure
would just walk into the press briefing
room without any
preparation because she just assumed she
wasn't going to get tough questions and
the republicans are always going to get
extremely tough usually unfair questions
and so they're just
simply better prepared in speaking of
transportation
news now that the vaccine mandate from
the biden administration could take out
37
of truckers during the holiday shopping
season
this coming from the american trucking
association truckload carriers
association international food service
distributors association other business
groups
are warning
the biden administration
that the vaccine mandate
could
lead to a 37 reduction in truckers the
industry is already short by about 30
so when when we say that the
the supply chain crisis is not joe
biden's fault sure there's some truth to
that
yes some of it is coming
after months and months of locking down
the world and not manufacturing things
in time and sure it's not all buddha
judge's fault for instance but some of
it is
some of it is and in the future a lot
more of it is going to be directly
attributable to joe biden that's smart
right in the middle of a supply chain
crisis as you've got the biggest
shopping season of the year coming up
make sure that we put almost 40 of
truckers out of business
not just the truckers
right now 28 at least 28 fire houses in
new york city
are out of service because of the
vaccine mandate
28 fdny
firehouses i'm sure this will be a great
relief when your house is on fire in
queens you know and you call up the fire
department
and you say help help my house is on
fire oh my gosh i can't get my my
children out in my oh i'm i'm burning up
in here and they'll say well ma'am we
don't have any fire trucks to send you
and no firemen to come rescue you uh but
don't worry you won't catch covid don't
worry yeah we don't because we don't
want to give you covet okay good luck
that's what's that's what's going to
happen in new york
and there is going to be pushback to
this even in blue new york even in blue
california even in these places that are
full of died in the wool liberals
when the basic elements of society break
down when you can't afford gas for your
car
when you can't call the fire department
when you can't win everyone in this
country can't get christmas presents
can't get their food for thanksgiving or
whatever
that there is going to be a pushback
because it doesn't matter how deeply
ideological you are when your society
can't perform even its most basic
functions
you can't deny
that the people running the society are
getting it wrong
speaking of new york
story in the new york post that i had to
bring up on the show today
classic new york post type headline
supposed to be a pretty wacky story here
my husband is gay but we're married with
two kids and have great sex
the woman for a beautiful woman the guy
good-looking guy the good-looking guy
apparently is not particularly attracted
to the good-looking woman but they're
married anyway and they have kids and
they
do the thing that married couples do
wow how kooky and crazy isn't it
this is an amazing story
it's amazing that this story is
considered so unusual
the there are mormons or at least the
the man is mormon
uh the mormon church says no you can't
do gay marriage or gay relationships and
if you have same-sex attraction you just
basically have to
repress it and
be celibate or chaste or but you can't
you can't engage in that and this guy
has decided to prioritize his religion
and his culture and his upbringing over
his sexual desires he's not deceiving
anybody that he's told this woman on
their first date that hey i'm a gay guy
i'm really basically just attracted to
to men
and she said oh okay and rather than
just
running away from him
she said actually it's kind of
it doesn't really bother me that
physical attraction is not the most
important thing in our relationship
actually she says she realized that he
was her guy that they were really and he
said that about her and they were really
meant to be together
and they broke up for a little bit when
he was trying to work through his sexual
desires
and then they got back together because
they missed each other
so it just wasn't a huge deal
he has with me his choice
what else mattered
now they're happy and they've got these
kids and okay
first of all
this is what gay guys did for like all
of human history
okay not not all okay some people would
be celibate or you know they'd be
confirmed bachelors or you know they'd
live with a very good friend of theirs
for a long time
but this was pretty common if you had
same-sex attractions you would just
repress it
as if you had any other
desire that you didn't want to live out
or engage in for whatever reason
religion culture tradition
now we're told that that's evil that
that's wrong if you have any desire you
have especially any sexual desire you
have to fulfill it
but my question for the sexual
revolutionaries who say that you
absolutely have to you know it's your
choice you have any choice you can
choose to be with
a man you can choose to be with a woman
you can choose to be with two men and a
goat you can choose whatever you want
and that's wonderful and we need to
celebrate all of that well why don't we
celebrate his choice
why
why is his choice not valid
he is he's being completely honest about
everything and he's just saying look i
would rather have the life
that comes with
being married to a woman
with kids
in my church community in my culture i
would i would rather make that choice
even if my
kind of instinctual desire
is look this is a this is a crazy world
it's a very diverse world
there's no end to the uh diversity and
eccentricity of human beings but he says
in my rational will and my conscious
will i'm just going to choose
to repress that that sort of desire and
i'm going to marry this woman and by by
the way he
he's being so clear here because
he's not saying that he's going to pray
away the gay as some people kind of
derisively call it he's not saying he's
ever going to completely eradicate this
desire from himself but it is simply a
case of desire
the case with desire rather that
habit helps to form our desires
so it's not like our desires are just
permanently fixed
right when we're little kids
we like milk chocolate we just love milk
chocolate but we can't see us lewis
makes this point you can't imagine that
there's anything better than milk
chocolate but as you grow you still like
chocolate but your desires can change
your tastes can develop you can develop
a taste for coffee you can develop a
taste for scotch
you can do when i was little my favor i
would love to play cowboys and indians
to get back to a point where we're
making earlier now i love to sit outside
with a book and a cigar when i was a
little kid i didn't want to sit outside
with a book or a cigar
not until i was 15 and i was a grown-up
boy now i don't like playing cowboys and
indians our desires actually change
as well and we can cultivate desires and
the more we practice certain habits
not that you're ever going to completely
get rid of some desire perhaps
but why do you not have that choice
it does show the intolerance the bigotry
the shallowness
of the left
and the the modern revolutionary view of
sex and identity and desire
that this the only thing that you're not
allowed to do
is
choose the more traditional
path that's the only thing you're not
allowed to do anymore
now speaking of sex stuff before we go i
have to get to this
the marines
have a job opening
okay now that's a tough job working for
the marines you know when you enlist
even if you become an officer
it's a tough job involves a lot of
sacrifice but you're serving your
country well no there's actually a
pretty cushy job in the marines right
now
a diversity
equity
and inclusion
advisor
the diversity equity inclusion advisor
for the united states marine corps
stationed at quantico virginia
starts at 144
128 a year
nice work if you can get it
people are really shocked and horrified
that the the marines have a diversity
equity and inclusion advisor but look
the marines always had a chaplain
and
back when our country believed in god
and was a christian country we had a
christian chaplain
now that our country is effectively an
atheist country in a secular country the
chaplain is just
the
director of diversity equity and
inclusion that's our national religion
that makes up our moral understanding
and metaphysical understanding of the
world
also reminds us of incentives
okay and the left is really good at
creating incentive we talk about what
how great we are on the economy here on
the right no the left understands
economic incentives a lot better if you
reward something with money and prestige
and privilege you are going to get more
of that thing and right now what our
society rewards
with
all sorts of compliments and plaudits
and cold hard cash
is the ideology of diversity equity and
inclusion is the ideology of the left
and they use the government to push it
and they use corporate america but they
use the whole political system
maybe the right
ought to do that too i'm michael nola's
the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
today on the ben shapiro show kyle
rittenhouse's trial goes completely
sideways for the prosecution lebron
james attacks kyle rittenhouse and biden
inflation is here and it's massive
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen